let's make a sex symbol I'm just gonna
put this there what people think makes
the sexy man has changed a lot over the
past hundred years we are going to be
recreating photos of the most
revolutionary male sex symbols
throughout history but they're only four
of us we're gonna be a little help from
some of our friends you're looking at
one yeah well yeah you will be because
that's what we're doing today I mean I
guess my great-grandmother might have
thought that he was steamy but she died
I'll be recreating Rudolph Valentino
who's that you ask well so did I he is a
film star in the 1920s and he is like
the original Latin Lover he played an
Arab lead character because as an
italian-american he was like the exotic
one the most popular male sex icon was
getting all this criticism for being
effeminate he was just beautiful all
around I feel like this is a theme we're
gonna see later like people are scared
what's too sexy I'm not supposed to be
talking am I
[Music]
he didn't even open his mouth then there
was a hundred thousand people as you
would that happen today if Justin Bieber
died he might get a hundred thousand
likes on a r.i.p Bieber photo I sought
to live up to so he was so adored that
Hitler wanted him as a pet which is I
guess I would take as a compliment I'm
delighted to play the king of Hollywood
especially because it's this old-school
funny sort of masculine he's always like
smiling and kind of winking even and
Gone with the Wind they're like what do
you think rat and he's like I don't know
if we can defeat the North we don't have
enough cannons he's almost like a proto
Clooney and that he was a Silver Fox at
a very young age he's just an old man
who has giant ears and a weird cat-like
grin so if I'm gonna be a sexy man I
want to be the weirdest looking sexy man
I can possibly be
hello my daughter died on a pony all of
these actors from back in the day they
were all soldiers they were laying their
lives on the line we don't have enough
cannons nowadays no one comes to mind I
don't think Channing Tatum's out there
yeah I look like a weirdo by today's
standards but that's okay I feel the
sexiest I've ever felt that real trick
is though not wearing anything under the
trench coat that makes it easier to have
sex with a thousand women hi I'm going
to be Humphrey Bogart Humphreys very
like serious and very stoic we look back
at the acting and all those old films
it's very over-the-top but he was very
grounded he was just that good of an
actor to know that yeah you just have to
do very little all these quotes talk
about how brilliant of an actor he was
how he started the Rat Pack and I would
do all these cool things and then you
find out that he also is super insecure
is like I don't know
am I really a sex icon I think that's
super relatable I think I'm incredible
but doesn't mean that I think every
beautiful woman will be swooned by me
I mean I feel sexier dressed as Humphrey
Bogart than I did before here's looking
at you kid
the trench throw in the Hat are
definitely like super sexy cigarette
don't smoke it's not good but it looks
so hot
[Music]
well there's the proof of him being a
sex icon right there regular bogey fest
I'll just make all the money and party
with my rat friends there's very few
people my mom has said are attractive my
mom has always been like Elvis Podesta
nice so beautiful so tanning - yeah I'm
very familiar with Elvis music he's one
of those artists that even if you're
young someone your family listens to
Elvis I'm he's an amazing musician what
really pushed that forward was just
someone being able to express who they
were in a very honest sexual way it's
crazy how revolutionary just being open
about your dick can be before Elvis you
had to beat you know macho and
chivalrous hell this kind of just threw
out the window he just rusted and let's
just skip all the dressing and get right
through the salad is that a gross
analogy I just made Elvis was opening a
lot of different doors culturally that
led into many of the movements that
happened in the 60s so I got a really
swing my dick forward basically okay -
okay
bugger thank you very much like a
blanket for my Turkish women you're
especially today when we see so many
different artists being able to like
showcase their bodies in ways that are
very freeing I think we owe a lot of
that to Elvis I think I put the pee in
Elvis get it Daisy you got a
okay lemon now am i doing Elvis or Cher
I can't quite tell it's all there but
thank you thank you very much so I'm
gonna be recreating Sean Connery that
was enough to I apologize to everyone
watching write out the best ball I think
a certain era of men like subscribe to
Sean Connery has their symbol for what a
man should look like this masculinity
defined he's the guy that gets all the
girls he drives the nice cars impeccable
taste in clothing and he gets there like
shoot guns and save the day
if you look like an athlete people kind
of assume that you don't have this sense
of class so instead of him just being a
kind of brutish tough guy they gave him
this this air of sophistication and
intelligence that's just sexy right now
a lot more fun and shake it
Josh sexiest man of the century share
your secrets please of the century I
don't even how you compete with that
I'll bet I've done what else is there
yours a man now dog of all the voters
were doing today this is the most try
guy's photo so I am honored just I was
gonna say step into his pose but I'm not
I'm stepping out of my clothes I am
recreating the infamous naked Burt
Reynolds photo when you think Burt
Reynolds you think - he thinks the body
hair he's dead sexy this was the first
time that a man had ever been naked in a
major magazine after this photo was
released Reynolds turned into a star
overnight
lined up outside of his apartment I've
taken so many naked photos and none of
them have catapulted me in a way it kind
of validated female sexuality because
guess what women like looking at naked
men too and so Burt Reynolds was like
hey ladies check me out so today I'm
gonna let all you check me out
he just had tons and tons of sex I know
what that's like that's good he just
looks like he's having a blast
he's just naked he's laughing he's on a
bearskin rug it's hilarious
I really just like slowly taking their
clothes become like the weirdest
historical tour never right there's only
one person who's supposed to have their
clothes off and I thought you got to
kind of steal my thunder there are a lot
of hairy dudes out there and so I'm
appreciative that there was at least one
of these sex symbols who like made it
really awesome and okay tree to embrace
your natural body the idea of playing 27
instruments like I can barely speak
English today I get the honour of
retreating an image of prints growing up
prints was always someone I was
intimidated by because maybe I saw a lot
of myself and prints I think he crossed
every barrier that there is musically I
think it takes a very creative unique
mind
that is one-of-a-kind one-in-a-million
to be able to cross so many different
music world for me and drogyny is
something that has always been something
I have been afraid of I've had to prove
in the fact that I was a man I guess
instead of embracing all the feminine
qualities of myself prince accepted
himself and loved himself [ __ ] do
this sexiness is he using muscles I
never knew had it's kind of this world
that we live in now and it's such a
beautiful world to be able to wear
[ __ ] lipstick or paint your nails and
feel accept it and I love it
Titanic leo - like wow that guy it's
like you saw him before wow this guy
looks like he's 15 but sexy I love Leo
are you gonna mention the he's on
growing pains because that's where I
first remember seeing it's not the name
to Leonardo DiCaprio come on crazy
confused cuz they still speaking of
Shakespeare imagine just being a barista
and your name's Lee be getting our dough
to come we have to be they like redid it
that gift oh my god on quaaludes and
stuff Reverend it was that was called my
thing was Leo in the back or the front
why do I imagine him in the front like
doing it and Rose was holding him I
think the closest thing to Leo in recent
memory is Justin Bieber or one direction
but I think even Leo then he just owned
the 90s girls would have like binders
and it'd just be like cutouts of him in
like magazines girls bedrooms would just
be laced with Leo I'm excited about Leo
banks hopefully he sees this and
hopefully we kick it on a yacht together
maybe turn them look at me one-two-three
he's so hot he cares a lot about the
environment and he's a great actor
okay what's the weird thing is he a
vampire have you ever thought about that
do I get my Oscar now I have to wait 20
years he won an Oscar for revenant
not the reverent he kind of makes shitty
tattoos look good which is how you know
you're really hot David Beckham has
created a life that as a kid he would
write down in France he was kind of like
a sex symbol for sports before that
became a thing my family is really into
soccer but even still my little brothers
will reference him and so he moves he
did he was a man babe and actually
really [ __ ] good at what he did that
idea that a man could be more in a style
and fashion especially straight a man
was kind of a new concept especially in
the early 2000s he kind of did the
rubber thing but then then evolved into
a dad and a husband which he's doing
well I think that was something really
new that we got to kind of see his path
we carried on
[Music]
him defining this idea of being
metrosexual set a bar for like what men
have to be now he shows a certain
confidence in his sexuality now I feel
like that's a lot more commonplace it's
interesting because the one thing that
links what people have seen as sexy in
men is just confidence body types change
hair styles changed but there's a
certain natural confidence which is
always hot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's crazy to see how much the idea of
what makes a man sexy is changed over
the past hundred years between all the
photos that we've taken today I would
encourage to see where it goes in the
next 50 years
Internet's forever huh yep great
[Music]
I think I need to across man Wow Wow
it's amazing